Je suis commandant Squeezie. Français de père en fils depuis 1818.
Nous allons diriger les plus grandes armées du pays !
Des soldats capable de faire un feu de camp avec seulement le bouchon d'un stylo Bic
Capable de couper du steak haché fraîchement chassé.
Capable en levant le petit doigt de se décrotter l'oreille.
Excellent !
Messieurs dames le début de la guerre commence.
Par contre je suis pas un joueur de ping-pong donc je sais pas pourquoi j'ai ça entant que général.
New game.
Alors voilà comment ça se présente;
C'est la phase un après c'est beaucoup plus amusant.
On a de la thune, chaque unité coûte de la thune.
Bon au début on va être des paysans.
La bonne France, la France de l’agriculture, la France des haricots verts on connait bien.
Et la on clique sur "play", et c'est parti !
Ils sont là, on est les rouges ils sont les bleus.
Attendez peut être on est les bleus ils sont les rouges je sais pas, je suis un mauvais commandant.
C'est pas grave.
Non nous on est les bleus, c'est sûr on est les bleus.
Et regardez, cette position, cette position comme on les as on les chevauche!
C'est un film porno d'une écurie..
Ah non on était les rouges.
En fait on va les mettre en file indienne.
Technique Peter Pan, technique Disney.
C'est parti !
A la file indienne, indienne, indienne
Ils sont pas en file indienne???
MAIS ILS RESPECTENT PAS MES ORDRES!
Attends je pense qu'on va les avoir la.
Allez baisez les bleus.
Aller les rouges! Allez les rouges!
On les a eu?
Ok 3 v 3
Ah on passe a 800 d'argents direct!
Dix fois plus!
*rires*
J'ai établi une stratégie que personne n'a jamais fait avant:
Une putain de rangé d'archers intouchables sa mère qui les baisent à 100 mètres !
Hop la !
Elle est belle.
Ah merde dans ce sens la en fait c'est une file indienne.
A la file indienne..
*cris des personnages qui meurent*
Oh putain.
Mais tirez pas sur vos collèges de devant!
Ok donc là, là ça va faire une vrai ligne.
C'est parti.
TIREZ!!!
APPRENEZ A VISER !!!
Mais ils savent pas viser!
Mais ça sert a quoi? C'est des archers aveugles!
Regarde le !
"Ah je sais pas où viser"
"Ahh il y a des ennemis?"
Archers plus jamais, brûlez-les,
Brûlez-les tous!
On va prendre des "Spearman".
Tu vois ça a l'air cheaté ça.
Play!
Oh mais là mec , c'est simple c'est comme une fourche
En deux fois plus long et deux fois plus pointu
ALLEZ-Y ! OUI !
CA EMPALE ! CA EMPALE !C'EST CA QU'ON VEUT!
Pourquoi ? pourquoi on perd ?
ça empalait bien jusque là
Il est tout seul , mail il a pas l'air choqué . Il à l'air serein.
Il tient tête , il tient tête.
C'EST NOTRE HÉROS , IL EST LA  !
HERCULE EST LA ,PERSONNE PEUT LE TEST ! QU'ES TU VA FAIRE ?
ON L'APPEL LE YOLO, IL LES BAISE UN PAR UN
IL EST DANS SON JACUZZI, ILS SONT DANS LEUR JALOUSIE!
Ah merde.
OK. Un "cannoncrew", seul contre tous.
On va bien le mettre derrière
C'est parti. TIRE! TU PEUT LE FAIRE !
VAS-Y !
Oooohhhh !
Ooohhh ! Vas y encore !
Ooohhh ! Encore.
Oui c'est ç... oh attend
*musique héroïque*
*cris de lapin crétin*
Euuuh
Bon là c'est chaud. Bon aller on appelle Mylène...Farmer.
Mylène Farmer.
Ah je suis colonel, j'ai pas dit que j'étais humoriste.
Le problème c'est qu'il faut laisser une ligne entre chaque truc.
Je pense que c'est ça. OK là on est bon normalement. On y va.
On y va ! On y va ! Allez les boucliers et derrière les lances !
Allez les gars ! COME ON ! LET'S DO THIS SHIT
On les empale ! On les empale !
Regarde il est tout seul. C'est incroyable ce 1 v 1.
Ce 1 v 1 divin de l'espace.
Oui ! Allez continue les coups de bouclier
Je crois en toi. Je crois en toi de toutes mes forces. Tu peux le faire.
Tu es un bon soldat.
*musique de guerre du Moyen-Age/Soviétique*
Ça n'évolue pas. Il fuit. Ça y est il va prendre la fuite.
Allez ! Seul contre tous.
Peut il le faire, la question est terrible et cruciale.
*PAM*
C'était notre meilleur homme.
Oh là mec je fais une strat' de malade, je vais pas vous mentir mon père était capitaine.
Tout devant on sait pas pourquoi on va mettre un bouclier pour les perturber.
C'est parti. Oh le mec en front line il a du courage.
Là j'ai fais un truc de malade.
Allez les archers. Allez vous visez bien. Oui ! Oui !
Ça marche ! Les archers ? Mais tuez pas nos potes.
Ça va passer. Ça va passer.
Oohh il est dernier
Il va mourir. Il va mourir.
Il va mourir ou pas ?
Mais tuez-le ! Mais.
Voila, putain.
Hey ! Jeanmichelj'aibesoinniquelemecsoitcollépourluimettreuneflècheentrelesdeuxyeux.
C'est trop long. Ok on est passé.
Ah maintenant on a moins d'argent. Qu'est ce qu'on peut faire ?
Moi j'aimais bien ma petite lignée de paysans comme ça là. Et derrière mettre les archers.
C'est parti. Ah c'est des boxers en face bon bah les flèches ça va le faire.
Oh mais non mais pourquoi tu as fais ça ?
(personnage) nique la république
Ah mais non ils sont la aussi, y a des archers j'avais pas vu.
Aaahhh ! 2 v 6
Ah ils ont fait un escadron d'archers dans le back les putes.
Comment tuer cet escadron ?
Mec je crois que j'ai trouvé.
Mais c'est de la douille, moi avec mes thunes je peux faire que ça.
*musique lyrique, triste*
Mais pourquoi ils savent pas viser ?
Ils peuvent pas vous tuer ! Ils peuvent pas vous tuer !
*musique lyrique, triste*
Mais les gars arrêtez de faire de l'acrosport !
Oh là là
*musique lyrique, triste*
Non mais là c'est chaud.
*pam*
OK OK ! J'étais sur la mauvaise version du jeu.
j'suis une grosse merde. Là on est sur la bonne on devrait y arriver plus facilement.
OK qu'est ce qui change ?
On a 500 de thune. En face ils sont 2-4-6 on va les baiser.
Ah maintenant il y a des stats, on en est là.
Seul contre tous il peut le faire.
Ça c'était mon barbare là
qui a explosé dès le début.
Non mais si je comprend bien ce mec qui agonise et qui rouspète
C'était mon barbare !
Mais heureusement j'en ai mis un deuxième
qui fait des grandes enjambées. Allez vas y tu y va tout seul.
hooo attaque surprise mec qu'est ce que tu vas faire!
t'es choqué? tes choque l’animation va jamais en acrosport
OOOOOUIIIIII! comment il les rekt
il est intouchable c'est incroyable!
et je parle pas du film avec Omar Sy.
*le barbare crie*
c'est pas La Fouine et pourtant qui peut le stopper?
et voilaaa! Je suis de retour
Mes capacitées ont augmentées. 1000 de money!  ha, mais la ils sont beaucoup!
Il y a un chicken man!? moi je veux un chicken man.
Fais moi rêver! Il m'a prit tout mes thunes j'espère qu'il est bon.
qu'est ce qu'il fait le chicken man?
y poop des poules!!!????
ho mon dieu!
sa marche tellement bien! haaa
comment il les nargue. il les baise avec son cul, egg-cellent
hoo nan sa pas duré
moi je veux voir un samourai master. aller on en met deux!
faites-nous rêver les gars!
Mais c'est la même animation que le barbare. pourtant c'est pas la même culture hein!
whoo ho non! ils sont tellement fort c'est incroyable
HOOO
il a fait un double kill a la fin. très très fort.
Ils sont super! ho ils sont beaucoup il y a des boucliers!
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre devant ? UN CHARIOT ?!
C'est quoi ça ? AAAH! MAIS C'EST LE PÈRE NOEL!
mais qu'es ce que mais qu'es ce que le père noël fout la
Et on va mettre des petits Samouraïs de part et d'autre
VOILA ON Y VA !!!
PETIT PAPA NOEL
oh il est super violent
Quand tu descendras du ci...
*crac*
noooon !! qu'est ce qui se passe ?!
Plus de cadeaux , plus de cadeaux pour cette année.
Et les Samouraïs ça donne quoi ?
D'accord et la catapulte ?
Putain il est super violent lui
Ah attends il va peut-être gagner attends tends tends
*crac*
OOh c'est dommaage
Alors attends équipage de canon c'est pas mal ça
*bip*
Et là on va mettre deux mecs à la hache
Et trois mecs qui juste se cogne la tête voilà on sait pas pourquoi
C'est fort les canons ou pas ?
Oh ouiii il m'a séduit ça y est
*pam,crac*
Oh la mauvaise idée  la mauvaise idée de cet homme
Attens là c'est chaud j'ai plus qu'deux canons je pense qu'il peuvent le faire
Ils tirent super vite !
Oh oui il va gagner
Regardez-le il sait ce qu'il attend et là !
*Musique de thug*
Incroyable ! Putain j'suis un très très bon capitain
Y'a des catapultes . C'est quoi les Barrelrollers ?
Allez les Barrelrollers je sais pas à quoi vous servir mais on y va
Eh bah voilà ils servent à rien ces grosses merdes !!
Ah si il foute le feu !
Ah si c'est pas mal quand même.
Le problème c'est les CATAPULTES!!
Oh mec tu va tellement prendre charge j'suis désolé
Ça arrive ça arrive !!!
*crac*
*work work work work*
ah c'est quoi ca? ah ca me plait
qu'es ce que ca fait?
*bruit de fléche*
*pan*
ah mais c'est pas mal mais apres quan y'en a plus y'en a plus
et vous es-ce que ca vous a plus?
*musique festive*
mais comment tu baise ces putain de catapulte
ah peut etre avec ca
*bip bip biiip*
ARMÉE
TIREEEZ!
*bruit d'arme*
c'est pas mal
mais l'avantage c'est que les gars ils baisent avec leurs boulets les autres la bas
vous pouvez le faire
eux ils esquivent ils sont... OH OUI!
MAIS ILS TIRENT DE SUPER LOIN
ca c'est fait
armée de bouclier bon  et on a que 1500
bon ça va être hyper simple
*biiiiiiiiiiiiiip*
c'est ma strategie aujourd'hui
ils vont lancer les... ah non ils ont qu'un javelot ah c'est nul
ils vont lancer un javelot et apres le mec tout nus il fait plus rien
nan mais attend les gars je veut bien que vous ayez un bouclier mais la ils encaisser beaucoup
oh mon gars c'est la folie les javelots
c'est incroyable ils en lance 6000
ILS PEUVENT PLUS BOUGER ILS SONT COINCER DANS LES LANCES TELLEMENT YA DES LANCES!!
*squeezie rit*
manequin challenge
*musique hip hop*
cette battle n'a aucun sens
ah non y'en a un avec une épee
*pam*
mais non tu peut pas le rater a cette distance c'est pas possible mec
voila aller le petit dernier las bas
il va s'embrocher tout seul fais le tour
j'te jure la ya pas de fin. CONTOURNE!
il va se tuer a force
*musique d'ascenseur*
*plaf*
*pfff*
la victoire la plus humiliante du 21ieme siecle
ok des lanciers avec des trucs
bon il faut quoi la on va faire les bourins
ok c'est ti-par on vous attend !
*pan*
voila
c'est comme ca qu'on regle les problemes ici bon les gars on se dit a bientot ciao
*musique*
voila
le petit dernier
*musique*
voila ca degage c'est quand que j'ai une etoile la pour recompense j'en ai marre j'ai pas d'etoile
ola ca ce joue avec 600 canon la
pas de soucis
un super boxeur seul contre tous va t il y arriver?
*musique**pam*
tu peut le faire
AAAAAH IL A VOLE
AAAAAAIE
*biiiiiiiip*
voila tres bien c'est passe mes fusiller sont en trains de dominer
ils on beaucoup joué a call of duty ca leurs a apris quelque choses sur les armes
*plaf*
sauf lui
voila j'ai gagne quoi il reste qui ya personne la bas il reste qui
ya personne las bas vous faites quoi?
mais qu'es ce que vous foutez?
qu'es  ce qu'il foute mais qu'es ce qu'ils foutent?
*musique de victoire*
ah ben voila
*cris du mec qui meurt*
qui c'est cette homme en peignoir?
ah c'est un chiken man
ok city park on fais ca avec que des instrument geniaux
*pan*
ah mais non mais les cannoniers ils sont pourris la
*pam*
*cris de lapin crétin*
oh mon dieu il a pris son envol on peut dire que son âme est parti au ciel
*ouverture de porte*
*cris de lapin crétin*
*squeezie rit*
putain je cris énormément quand je suis général *racle la gorge*c'est incroyable ma gueule comme dans les films
*cris de squeezie*
bon ok j'envoie trump voila normalement c'est fini
(trump) thank you thank you ve...
*pan*
c'est fini
on va tester les trucs qui tirent de loin
*pan*
ils se font niquer par des poules pour de vrai regardez voila
les poules trop vénère c'est parfait
met un coup de fusil dans le cul de la poule putain
ah c'est gagné j'ai gagné j'ai parlé trop vite
oh ca pars sur quoi bon je veut voir des mecs qui font du taekwondo
tequendo vs armes blanches
oh c'est tellement beau c'est tellement beau les arrives comme ca
eh ben voila regardez les boucliers et les haches on s'en fout
nous on fais du taekwondo mon gars nous on saute on utilise les membres de notre corps
c'est très très beau
plus qu'un
*pam*
aller
oh ils sont chiants eux bon ce qu'on va faire
*bip*         *bip**bip*
voila la normalement c'est gagné l'asie contre finalement les vikings aller on y va
*flèches**pan*
mais non les gars vous pouvez pas vous pouvez pas tirez sur nos potes de devant
oh les ninja ils font trop mal mec regarde ils craignent personne EN PLUS ILS RECULENT LES NINJA LES PUTES TOUT EN LANÇANT LEURS SHURIKENS
a la la c'est une technique que je leurs aient aprise
alors on a du mal hein avec sa hache  et sa vieille coiffe de... d'ours
on est claque mon pote
la France
ben voila les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur total qngbgbjnfbjnfhbnbj
le nom impossible a dire
j'espere que ça vous auras plus si c'est le cas n’hésitez pas a spammer le pouce bleu
CA servira a rien vous pourrez cliquer qu'une fois
eh ben j'adore les jeux de ragdoll j'adore les jeux ou... ou c'est de la pure physique
tu peut placer tes soldats au même endroit  tu fais play 2 fois d'affilé il se passera pas le même truc j'aime beaucoup
voila j’espère que ça vous a plus c'était général Squeezie
des a présent je me démunie de mes fonctions j'ai eu mon étoile voila je la scotche ici
exellent c'est au fait un pot de gel rose j'ai tué des milliers de gens et gagne des dizaines de guerre pour avoir ce pot de gel
aller  c'est nul a chier portez vous bien ciao tout le monde *fume une pipe* PEACE